la nave soyuz tm 31 parte del cosmódromo
de baikonur su lanzamiento representó el
comienzo de una nueva era de cooperación
internacional en la conquista del
espacio un contraste con las luchas
anteriores entre eeuu y la unión
soviética los rusos o yuri guidzenko
sergei krikalyov y el estadounidense
william shepherd llegaron dos días
después convirtiéndose en la primera
tripulación permanente del módulo desde
entonces más de 200 astronautas de casi
20 países se han desplazado a la ciudad
espacial y cada día aprendemos algo
nuevo encontramos algo que resulta de
una manera diferente a la que
esperábamos descubrimos cómo arreglar
cosas que nunca planeamos hacer
allanando en este laboratorio que
aproveche la reducida microgravedad para
realizar experimentos imposibles en la
tierra involucra a eeuu rusia la agencia
espacial europea canadá japón brasil y
ucrania 20 años después es el objeto más
grande y pesado en la órbita terrestre
pesa 450 toneladas y ocupa una
superficie similar a la de un campo de
fútbol aún así se mueve una velocidad
promedio de casi 28.000 kilómetros por
hora
y completó las 16 órbitas a la tierra
cada día de este programa la estación
espacial internacional es un excelente
ejemplo de lo que las personas y los
países pueden hacer cuando tienen un
objetivo común when the heart of common
go además de hitos en la estación ha
vivido momentos trágicos como el
accidente del transbordador
estadounidense de columbia en 2003 que
se estrelló minutos antes de su
aterrizaje en cabo cañaveral y causó la
muerte de sus siete tripulantes un revés
que obligó a la nasa a interrumpir los
vuelos tripulados pese a esto el
programa siguió perfeccionándose y se
trata de objetivos ambiciosos a futuro
como la instalación de una base
permanente en la luna o el envío de una
nave tripulada a marte